la france perd son président la famille
gaulliste est aussi assez ses
inspirateurs et ussel et les français ou
un certain moment contestée la réaction
politique de jacques chirac
en revanche ils n'ont jamais douté de
l'affection et de l'amour qui leur
portent elles toute la famille de droite
aujourd'hui très triste parce que chirac
c'est une partie de notre histoire c'est
la victoire de 95 c'est voilà c'était le
fondateur du rpr quelqu'un qui avait
voulu que le gaullisme reviennent
gaullisme originel
et puis ensuite c'est un homme de combat
politique je crois que c'est pas
simplement la droite en fait c'est la
france font mentir et créatifs en adn
jacques chirac 50 hommes qui a marqué
bien sûr ma vie mais qui a marqué notre
époque marquée à vie politique
chirac ont été comme nous proche de nous
et qui parle à n'importe quelle personne
de quelle que soit la classe sociale
parler de la même manière donc on est né
chirac alors ouais repères évidemment
les mais sans doute un peu plus
qu'ailleurs mais on est méchant
nous aimions chirac et et lui nous
l'aurons des liens qu'il était à la fois
enracinés et universel enraciné d'abord
dans sa terre natale sa terre de corrèze
qu'il a beaucoup aimé qu'il a beaucoup
servi mais aussi à paris dans la
capitale
c'était un homme qui aimait les paysages
et les visages de france il était sans
doute un des meilleurs connaisseurs de
la france dans toute sa profondeur
territoriale et je sais que je n'aurais
jamais fait de politique sans la
présence extérieure de jacques chirac
son charisme était
évidemment très fort son énergie aussi
était extraordinairement puissantes
il a su créer une droite moderne
respectueuse des autres très large
républicaine au meilleur sens du terme
il ya aussi la valeur et que porter
jacques chirac la volonté de faire en
sorte que des français ce tacle vivre
ensemble chirac est quelqu'un qui ne
voulait pas que les français
s'affrontent
il voulait la réconciliation nationale
[Musique]